We would now like to apply the
momentum principle to analyze
the motion of the rocket.
So what is our
momentum principle?
We know that the
external force at time t
is equal to the rate of
change of the momentum
of the system over t.
Now, recall we're
going to actually use
the formal definition of
a derivative to write this
as a limit as delta t
goes to 0 of the momentum
of the system at
time t plus delta t
minus the momentum of the system
at time t divided by delta t.
So in order to
analyse the rocket,
what we need to do is separately
analyze the momentum at our two
states.
So we have a state at time t.
And we have a state at
time t plus delta t.
And our goal will be to analyze
the system momentum at time t,
and separately the
system momentum and time
t plus delta t.
And then we can apply
the momentum principle.
So let's begin by analyzing
the system at time t.
So recall that at that
time, we had our rocket
and this is our time t.
And the rocket had a
velocity V of r or t.
And what we identified
the mass, m-r of t--
recall this was the mass--
the dry mass of the rocket
and the mass of the fuel.
And so now, it's very simple
to write down the momentum
of our system at time t.
That's equal to just the
mass m of r of t times
the velocity of the
rocket at time t.
And so we can use
that in our expression
for the momentum of the system.
Now our next step is to
consider the system the time
t plus delta t.
Now recall, we still
have the rocket
but the mass of the
rocket has changed.
That's inside the
rocket, so this
is dry mass of the rocket
plus mass of the fuel,
but recall some of the fuel
has been ejected outwards.
So how do we depict that
in our momentum diagram?
Well let's just symbolize
that by a certain amount
and we're going to
call this delta m-fuel.
Now, what we need to do, again,
is to have our velocities.
So here, the velocity
of the rocket
is now the velocity at
time t plus delta t.
And what about the velocity of
this fuel that's being ejected?
Well, in our problem the
fuel is ejected at a velocity
u relative to the rocket.
So what we have is
u is the velocity
of the fuel relative
to the rocket.
But we've been choosing
the ground frame
as our reference frame.
And the rocket is
moving at a velocity
at time t plus delta t with
respect to that ground frame.
And so recall that the velocity
of the fuel in the ground frame
is equal to the velocity
relative to the rocket
plus the speed of the
rocket with respect
to the ground frame.
And that's what we're going
to draw on our diagram
as the fuel.
And so now we can
finish this analysis--
and we'll apply that
next-- is to right
the momentum of the system
at time t plus delta t.
Now this is going
to have two terms.
It has the mass of
the rocket at time t
plus delta t times the
velocity of the rocket.
And we also have to
add mass of the fuel
times the velocity of the fuel
with respect to the ground.
And now we have the momentum
at time t plus delta t.
So we have both of
our pieces here.
And we still have a
little bit of analysis
because we'll use
our mass conservation
equation and our relative
velocity condition
to simplify this expression.
So we'll do that next.